hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
the first monday
of 2022
january 3rd 2022
2000 and doug
flutie oh we got it he did it he did it
flutie did it
um the orange ball 1984. i'm sorry
what's going on man what's going on man
how was your new year
is it your new years
is it the finals
new year's eve
new year eve new year's eve happy new
years happy new year
coming up is new year's eve
but then you say happy new year i think
that's how it is
i don't know
whatever i like to mispronounce things
it makes people who are like marginally
smart
feel like they're geniuses
actually
the proper way to say it
is the stanley cup final there's only
one of them oh thank you
[ __ ] smarty [ __ ]
so dumb i didn't have a good insult
smarty [ __ ] yeah i'm going with smarty
[ __ ] speaking of smarty [ __ ] um
guess what we're doing guess what we're
doing since this goddamn pandemic
started we're doing the patrice o'neal
stand-up comedy benefit once again it is
back after a one-year
layoff due to influenza of the 2019
variety um
what is it going to be january 18th at
the new york city center
um tickets are on sale that new york
nycitycenter.org the lineup listen to
this lineup pete
davidson chris d stefano mateo lane
yamaneka saunders sherrod small
cipher sounds mike vecchio rich voss
hosting as always
and from the impractical jokers
and and taste buds podcast sal volcano
and yours truly
i mean what a lineup
uh come on down
uh it's a great benefit it's what we do
to help out uh
you know the people patrice was taking
care of um
you know
basically
stepping up for him
i can't believe he's already been gone
for 10 years but that's sad so we're not
gonna talk about that let's just plow
ahead
all right cause it's the new year you
know what happens in the new year you
get a new outlook
right you wake up you're like you know
what i'm gonna do this year i'm gonna
get some [ __ ] done
i'm gonna get some [ __ ] done that's what
i did this morning i woke up right my
daughter was a little sick
you know so um
you know how to deal with that overnight
you know she got sick a couple of times
so i woke up in the morning badou badou
boop and uh my son was fine so i brought
him downstairs
and i made him a little uh almond
smoothie
just [ __ ] delicious peanut butter
cinnamon
you know bananas and all of that stuff
he loves it does not want to use the
straw he wants to try to gulp it down
like he's drinking out of a solo cup and
if i don't let him do that
he pretends to cry runs over to the
couch and puts his head down on it and
pretends to cry and then he looks up to
see if i care it's hilarious
so um
anyway i was taking care of my son while
my wife and daughter slept in and uh
i don't know took all the dishes out of
the dishwasher because i'm getting [ __ ]
done it's 20 22.
you know that that first 53 years of
bill burr that was just a fluke
all right i'm getting now this is the
new bill burr he gets [ __ ] done right so
i [ __ ] empty the dishwasher
do all the dishes from the breakfast i
wipe down all the counter i get out the
vacuum
vacuum up the [ __ ] kitchen floor
then i go into the uh
the laundry room
there's clothes there clean clothes that
need to be folded took the ones that
were hanging down folded those took the
ones that were sitting in the laundry
basket emptied those out folded all
those [ __ ] things
took them upstairs put them all away
then cleaned up my side of the bedroom
and now i'm just like all right now now
what else can i do so i can feel like
hey i got momentum here
all right with three days in i got
momentum
you know i had a little bit of my side
of my garage got painted
so it didn't look like a [ __ ] eyesore
and then it looked beautiful
beautiful cream-colored wall the whole
thing i [ __ ] loving it and then what
happens like a month later it rains
and all this rust [ __ ] from the roof of
gutters or whatever just leaked down and
i'm like oh i can just wash that off no
you can't no you can't it's seeped into
the [ __ ] paint
so i'm gonna take a sponge
and a bucket of hot water and soap to it
today see the best i can do and then
maybe put another coat on get get a
[ __ ] roller
um
i'm getting [ __ ] done people it's the
new year okay i'm gonna get [ __ ] done
that matters all these t-shirts that i
should throw out but i can't cause
they're sentimental to me i got one of
those shrinky bags i'm gonna get the
vacuum cleaner i'm gonna [ __ ] open
the thing up stick the bags in there and
then shrink wrap it wrap it and stuff it
under the bed right
some [ __ ] getting [ __ ] done what are
you guys doing huh
i tell you what i've been dropping
weight
oh billy freckles oh billy freckles has
been going to the gym hitting that
elliptical
throwing around the weights a little bit
a little bit i've been kind of hanging
from the pull-up bar making my shoulders
feel better
uh not with my feet off the ground
although i did that a couple times
before i realized i wasn't supposed to
do that
um
shoulder feels pretty good i got an
acting gig coming up so it's like all
right
i got to get you know i got to be 172.
you know that's that's the way they have
to be at any less than that people think
i have aids anything more than that they
call me billy fat tits so uh that's what
i have to get down to so
um
that's just is what it is that's what
i'm that's what i'm gonna [ __ ] do so
actually got a uh it can't be 11 41 are
you [ __ ] kidding me how the [ __ ] is
it 11 40 what's 10 41.
oh my laptop's on [ __ ]
arizona time by the way thank you to
everybody who came out
uh
to my two shows my last two shows at
2021 in arizona
um
i had so much [ __ ] fun man they just
were i don't know maybe it was the
holidays everybody was in a good mood or
something
but like i just had a great time
making fun of arizona and then making
fun of hollywood all at the same time
so there was enough on either side you
know it's kind of what you want to do i
feel
be like all right you're kind of stupid
too but so are we and then you find the
middle ground everybody's like all right
he's going to give as well as he takes
and then you just have a good time
for the most part i feel like that's how
it went
um
but anyway uh let's talk like let's talk
about the [ __ ] college football
playoffs
the playoffs
it was representing the big ten the
michigan wolverines
for the first time forever it wasn't you
know all the ohio state buckeyes
they did not have a good season they
played like three good teams and they
lost to two of them
and that would not stop their fans from
still probably saying they should have
been in the playoff but i think
um after yesterday's rose bowl when you
let up 45 points to [ __ ] utah i think
at that point maybe
you could say next year but they did
come back and win they also led up 45
points who's getting new the sec looked
a lot stronger
um yesterday the i'll tell you the south
one that's what happened if you
reenacted the civil war on a football
field
um the north lost that one jesus christ
cincinnati well first of all michigan
just got absolutely [ __ ] destroyed i
mean they just got [ __ ] destroyed and
what i loved about georgia was they were
playing football what do you mean by
that bill i mean if you get down to the
[ __ ] red zone and it's fourth and
three fourth and five you don't [ __ ]
go for it you kick a field goal and you
take the [ __ ] points
you give your [ __ ] defense something
okay all right we got some points okay
now we stop them here maybe they'll go
down next time they'll score a [ __ ]
touchdown
everybody plays it now like they're
[ __ ] sitting at home playing a
goddamn video game and i know they i say
this to [ __ ] death but if you watched
that goddamn cincinnati alabama game
i mean i'm not saying cincinnati was
going to win but do you have to help
alabama cincinnati wins the [ __ ] toss
and the analytics
that they got from the math team nerds
right they let nerds coach their [ __ ]
team evidently analytics says you defer
it gives you a higher percentage
right
here's my belief about analytics from
someone who sucked at math
okay i suck at math but i'm great at
reading people
okay and i find people on math teams are
like great between the ears but they
can't feel out vibes they don't know
what the [ __ ] going on
okay and if you're going to take the
analytics you learned from when your
team was playing ball state and also put
it up against alabama that's probably i
mean i hope that's thrown in there for
error
right
that was like back in the day when i
used to [ __ ]
watch people say peyton manning was
better than tom brady and tom brady had
three super bowl rings
and peyton manning had yet to get one
they're still going you know i gotta
tell you you know i gotta tell you i
gotta tell you you know if you look at
the stats
if you're gonna build the team you gotta
go with peyton
it was just at that point peyton manning
was the guy if you wanted 500 yards and
six touchdowns in november that's who
the [ __ ] you wanted but if you wanted a
super bowl ring you wanted tom [ __ ]
brady
so anyways
peyton manning came around and he won
two super bowls i mean one of them you
know they made how we covered his
receivers illegal and then they stole
our offense but that's not cheating
um
i will never let that go neither way i
let this field go [ __ ] go so cincinnati
comes out
wins the toss
wins the [ __ ] toss they defer to
alabama who by the way
their quarterback is the heisman trophy
winner this year you know what we're
going to do wait wait this one we're
going to go out there if we win the toss
no matter what we're going to give it to
that kid
so what do they do evidently cincinnati
had some good corners so what do they do
they play big ten football they smash
mouth the ball all the way down the
field nice long sustained drive
go up seven to nothing and for the rest
of the game cincinnati's [ __ ] chasing
them because they're chasing them every
time they get in the [ __ ] red zone
they're going for it
at one point it was 24 to six it should
have been [ __ ] 24 to 12. they had two
chip shot field goals you just leave him
you just every time
it's like if you went to a casino and
every time you hit
every time you go double or nothing
you're gonna [ __ ] lose
you got to chip away at a [ __ ] team
like that keep your team in the [ __ ]
game so what happens
after all the effort the defense is
doing holding that powerhouse offense to
only 24 [ __ ] points
they should have been in the game and
they weren't every time they look up
they still see they only got six points
on the board and next thing you know
they have a frustration penalty that
that guy in cincinnati [ __ ] slaps the
helmet off the alabama kid he gets
kicked out of the [ __ ] game does he
do that analytic people if it's 24 to 12
i say he doesn't
if you watch georgia georgia scored on
every single drive except one and buried
michigan in the first half
you know why because if the touchdown
was there they took it if it wasn't they
got a [ __ ] field goal
that was the one thing i felt was
missing in that great john madden
uh documentary
was uh
they never asked him
what he thought of
the way the game was played today with
going for it
on fourth and two at your own 50-yard
line when you're down seven to nothing
in the first quarter
or going forward on fourth and five when
you're down by like 16
with almost two full quarters to go
take the points
it's so [ __ ] stupid i gotta tell you
something right now but if you're a
football coach in the upper deck of the
stadium agrees with the way of your
coaching calls i think you need to step
back i do anyway
when someone in the upper deck can
basically coach the team i'd go for it
fake pun
i don't know i thought it was [ __ ]
ridiculous and um
now that i've said that
what i you know i always root against
alabama because i came to college
football late i rooted for michigan when
i was growing up but like i was a pro
team and i wasn't just gonna jump on the
bandwagon you know when they have the
paul brown bill belichick of of uh
you know college coaches what i love
about watching the way alabama plays
is even when they play against a really
great team which cincinnati was
they can almost lull the other team into
this sense that
you know they have a shot
while all along the way alabama keeps
winning those little battles and then
next thing you know the game starts
slipping away and then the other team
gets frustrated and then they just get
blown out but for that first half
they're like yo we're doing all right
we're only down by [ __ ] seven
and then they just do some dumb [ __ ]
they take [ __ ] penalties they get
kicked out of the [ __ ] game they just
do dumb [ __ ] like that they're just an
unbelievable
program and an unbelievably coached team
and uh and you know what that sets up
now
that sets up an all south
georgia verse alabama the inevitable
battle that would have happened
if the south won the civil war there
would have been a second civil war no
one in the south wants to talk about it
because they act like they're all on the
same page but here's the deal georgia
and alabama do not like each other
all right
they like that what's what's that show
about those rich people who they're all
[ __ ] [ __ ] to each other so you
can't really root for anybody secession
succession
you know
you're like you're trying to be
emotionally invested
like oh my god i can't believe this
character did that to that other
character but it's like well
the character out of the character just
did that too did this to the other
character you know i don't give a [ __ ]
about him this is just like
voyeuristic uh just watching terrible
behavior
which by the way i don't understand i
was on the elliptical right billy
balliptical
um
and i'm watching you know they show all
all of these legendary people that
passed away last year i mean it was
[ __ ]
incredible like just
from paul from colin powell
to [ __ ] dusty hill to [ __ ] dmx
just all of these
amazing people in politics military
artists music
sports the whole [ __ ] thing and then
in the middle of it they put [ __ ]
bernie madoff
it's like what in the [ __ ]
how does he make a [ __ ] list
i love that i didn't even know he died
that's the way a guy like that should
die
anonymously in [ __ ] jail
i don't know
it really [ __ ] annoyed me
at first i was excited i was like oh
that piece of [ __ ] died i didn't even
know that then i'm like wait a minute
what the [ __ ] did dmx colin powell and
dusty hill do to deserve to be on the
same list as [ __ ]
bernie [ __ ] madoff
um
anyway let's get back georgia versus
alabama all right they do not like each
other
okay now on the football field i believe
georgia is the underdog
i believe i i don't know i think they're
ranked i forget who's ranked one who's
ranked number two but i'll tell you in
life
alabama
is the underdog if you go to georgia
people in georgia love to trash people
in alabama
people in georgia feel that they are a
cut above
that they're brisket
is a little more eloquent
than alabama's ribs right
the people i mean i think you know it
all depends on what you want if you're
just going
if you're just looking at this like a
sports fan
all right
you got to root for georgia
just because you know alabama seems to
win it all the time
all right
but if you want to be woke
you know georgia abuses their power
over alabama
you know georgia has slightly better
books in their school
you know only slightly better which is
why they still do the tomahawk chop at
the world series
in alabama i mean you're talking about a
state that thinks the hunger games is a
documentary
okay a lot of them do
okay now i'm speaking from personal
experience having performed in both
states
knowing full well that i'm better than
all of those people combined
all right
i'm [ __ ] with you guys um but i
didn't notice that when i went to
georgia uh
like
they all they would make fun of people
from alabama all the time the way people
from wisconsin make people from people
from illinois ohio with [ __ ] uh
michigan it's just states think other
states are dumber than they are
i don't know why especially if you live
like right on the [ __ ] state line
you know they had that new england
mass holes maniacs
you know i don't know i don't know what
[ __ ] people rhode island everybody
thought were morons
connecticut they were a bunch of rich
[ __ ]
it's uh you know
i got to be honest it's kind of true
though
um
no i'm [ __ ] with you so anyway that
is gonna be the championship game for
the championship for all the marbles
alabama first
georgia
and uh
i don't know
who knows i'm gonna be rooting for
georgia only because alabama
wins it all the time but i i love both
of those programs i love the sec and
they definitely proved that they were
the best conference this year
because uh
you know
because of the two games that you
[ __ ] watched
you know i got a buddy of mine that was
watching him and he's going you know
college football [ __ ] stinks it's
like the playoffs have been great except
when ohio states gets in there he gets
[ __ ] destroyed like more like nine
times out of ten
um god i love trash in ohio state
i don't even i don't even not like the
program it's just their fans are such
whiny [ __ ]
you know as i whine about field goals
for [ __ ] 20 minutes on this podcast
um
yeah
college football stinks what [ __ ] are
you talking about
i love college football they still kick
field goals and polls
some people do
um
so anyway
that is my recap as a non-athlete
uh oh by the way i went to the road i
went to the rose bowl yesterday we
didn't go to the game that's the new
thing that we do we just go to the
tailgate and just realized at the end of
the day what we really enjoyed was the
tailgate
and um i know that was an amazing game
yesterday but like you know that was
utah's first [ __ ] time ever being at
the rose bowl do i really need to go buy
four of those tickets or can four more
people from utah go you know
uh all right bill let's not make
yourself the hero here the reality was
you wanted to sit on a golf course smoke
as many cigars as you could and eat
brisket that's exactly what i wanted to
do while a stealth bomber flew right
over our [ __ ] tailgate
i gotta post that [ __ ] video right
now you guys are gonna get exclusive
audio of a video how exciting is that
you just got to hear this thing this is
the stealth bomber flying over
yeah we listen to the car it's crucial
old here comes
sounds like a regular jet right what's
that southwest
[Applause]
wait for it
any other car alarms
oh that's amazing
the reality is if a southwest jet flew
that [ __ ] law we didn't see what that
thing could do
you know
i told i always tell you guys that
aviation story i heard where some guy
you know
was flying was was on
whatever you are when you're in between
a approach or departure whatever radio
when you're in the in route structure of
your flight
uh this guy you know he calls for an
altitude check
in typical you know
human being [ __ ]
i guess if you're at a higher altitude
that means you're a [ __ ] you know
better pilot or something it usually
does because then you're gonna start
pressurizing your cabin which means you
have a [ __ ] sick ass plane which
means you have more training than people
at lower altitudes i guess i guess
that's how it works
so
somebody heard that
somebody else flying and they knew that
this guy was just peacocking
about how he was at like 14 000 feet so
some commercial person just did an
altitude check
you know
but whenever somebody they were like 18
000 and then somebody else gets in on it
they're like whatever
30 something thousand and you think
that's the end of it and for whatever
reason this is the i don't know if this
is true because i would think they'd be
on like some military frequency but
somebody flying like the stealth bomber
called in and they were up at like i
don't know what they were at but all i
know is the the height that they fly
like above 60 000 feet or some [ __ ]
when they take off from st louis when
they get up to altitude they were saying
that they can see
like
um denver colorado vegas
and
los angeles and the ocean then they make
a right turn and they can literally see
as they're flying up
you know san francisco san jose
sacramento
portland and seattle are just way off in
the distance and then they go up and
they fly back i mean how [ __ ]
insane
is that can you imagine being in the
front of that car picture sitting there
looking at that
i just want them to take one flat
earther up there just to see that
they would blame the windshield they put
us they put a fisheye windshield
on it why am i making the person
southern like there's no flat earthers
in the north dude you know what they did
they had an effect it's a fisheye lens
like beastie boys used to use for their
videos that's all they did you know
i knew it they knew i knew it that's why
they landed early
um
anyway um so we hung out and we had a
little tv and a generator so we watched
the game
and we just had like a [ __ ] blast man
and i gotta tell you the utah people i
don't we got there a little later too so
i got to like sleep in because i went
out with my wife the night before
um
you know to a little new year's thing
mashed up or whatever young kid's not
messed up they know they're gonna beat
it they don't give a [ __ ] let's kill
some old people let's let's free up some
corner offices
let's make this college degree be worth
something i get it i get it go out there
kill some people young people do it do
it
um before every summer is nothing but a
giant fire
um
all right and with that happy [ __ ]
news um
i am recording right now uh 10 59 a.m
pacific coast time
so the nfl games have just started
and um
you know i'm recording a few of them so
i'm not gonna be talking nfl here but i
will talk a little bit of a little for
the first time in 22 2022 2022
is our old friend's own
zip
crew zip recruiter everybody
if you work for if you work for or own a
business in one of those growing
industries
wait if you work for or own a business
in one of those growing industries what
growing industries a wide range of other
industries you probably need to hire
asap i feel like i missed some copy
there
if you work
for or own a business
in one of these growing industries
what growing industry
growing weed
online porn
or a wide range of other industries you
probably need to hire
asap um asap asap
that's what he's supposed to say because
asap might as well say as soon as
possible
as soon as possible asap
slightly faster asap
that's bud fox crushing it on wall
street asap all right there's only one
place to go zip
or right now you can try it for free at
ziprecruiter.com
zip
uses powerful technology to find and
match the right candidates up with your
job you don't want to [ __ ] around
all right and put your job up on some
pegboard down at the [ __ ] y and every
goddamn lunatic smelling like [ __ ]
ben gay coming walking in you want
quality candidates
all right then
it proactively presents these candidates
to you
okay you can easily review these
recommended candidates and invite your
top choices to apply for your job so if
you look at these your top candidates
and you look at somebody and you're like
buddy
i don't like your face
i'm stealing that guy from uh reservoir
dogs i'm gonna shoot you in the face
you don't put your [ __ ] hands on that
dashboard um yeah you don't like the way
somebody's face looks like i don't want
to [ __ ] look at that i don't give a
[ __ ] how good they are i don't want to
look at that face
40 hours a week and that's one of the
beauties of running your own business is
you can say that to yourself
can't say it to anybody else back in the
day you could say that
you go right down to the old cafeteria
and [ __ ] take that face and put it up
on the wall and use it as a dartboard
and everybody would laugh because they
feared your power
because you didn't have a little cell
phone where you could videotape it tell
people that you didn't feel safe
you just had to sit there not feeling
safe
you know
trying to steady your hands even open
your brown bag not trying to wrestle it
too much
you know to betray your cowardice in
front of your [ __ ]
abusive boss but that's a different
story
anyways which just encourages them to
apply faster no no wonder
zip
is the number one rated hiring site in
the us based on g2 ratings
not g3 g2 we're slowly working our way
up the ladder zip recruiters technology
is so effective that four to five
employers who post on zip
get a quality candidate within the first
day and now you can try ziprecruiter for
free at this exclusive
web address it's a very exclusive app
web address you know
not a lot of people have web addresses
on the internet but they have one
ziprecruiter.com
z-i-p-r-e-c-r-u-i-t-e-r
didn't work out dot com slash bird that
zip
[Applause]
spell it out z-i-p-r-e-c-r-u-i
that's what's going to get you u-i
t-e-r
the smartest way to hire
ui
that reminds me of that bowler talking
[ __ ]
who do you think you are i am
it's one of the greatest things ever
just wanting to talk [ __ ] knowing you
got the camera and you got nothing he
just he just plowed through it who do
you think you are i am
um
all right so
one of the things that i've been talking
to people about
you know as uh
the world seemingly gets crazier and
crazier or is it just that you're online
listening to people who aren't that
smart
who are scaring the [ __ ] out of you or
are you arguing with a russian bot
you know i really believe all you have
to do
to get a job in russia in the government
is to be able to write in english
welcome to biden's america
or
if you can type well you can blame the
trump administration for all trump
administration be a little trouble you
can blame trump for that one that's all
you need to do and you will get at least
40 to 50 americans typing in capitalism
and just wasting their [ __ ] afternoon
hating each other more and more
all right what i want to do is i want to
get on russian
instagram
then i want to start trolling them
but how do you troll people that live
under a dictator
well you can thank vladimir putin for
that and they're going to be like yeah
or die
[Music]
i mean that's
really don't have choices
people in russia i don't want to get
anybody in trouble
all right
if you're listening over there but
how funny are those [ __ ] vladimir
putin scoring goals on the ice
jesus christ
i love after he shoots it i love the
three second delay by the goalie before
he flops and tries to lift up his leg ah
christ they're probably gonna send some
russian [ __ ] over here to send some
[ __ ] poison mist on the side of my
neck when i'm on the elliptical
do you know what the locker room is uh
no i can't do a russian
there accent
go i can at least do the spray sound
um
you must hear me uh dictator rules for
fatty so i've been asking people what
they would do
if they were a dictator
um
i would do a bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ] that
people wouldn't like but it would be i i
feel it would be good for everybody
you know and if that right there isn't
the most cliched statement made
by anybody who wants to be a dictator
i'm going to do a bunch of [ __ ] that no
one wants me to do but it's going to be
good for him i know what's good for all
of you
all right
i would be like this is why i would also
fail because i watched that video on how
power works
and people are just all about money
so you'd have to [ __ ] eliminate money
how do you eliminate money let's go back
to the barter system i don't know what
happens human beings are just flawed
okay in a perfect world as a dictator
all right
i would uh
i would go environment
i'd go education
and i'd go uh and then also animals
well animals are also part of the
environment i watched this [ __ ] video
the other day this guy went to the
grocery store his fish tank was empty
and he was thinking uh
about you know what new petty one and he
saw these lobsters sitting in
uh sitting in the in the little tank
there he decided to get one and just
have it as a pet
and when he took you know the rubber
band off that little thing that they
stick in there i thought the things
claws would immediately come out they
didn't
they were all [ __ ] atrophied like you
know when you get frozen shoulder
because you don't keep moving your arms
or whatever because you have a [ __ ]
rotator cuff issue had the same thing
and this guy like basically rehabbed
this lobster back
because it was sitting in fresh water
and they hadn't been fed or anything and
he started feeding it and then he had
this little rubber tube
that he would stick down there and let
him
in his left claw opened and closed but
his crusher one
on the right wasn't working
i didn't realize how many [ __ ] arms
those things had
they're like little dark ox you just see
the thing and you see how he's excited
it is to be alive and feeling better and
everything
and i just i just so [ __ ] wrestle
with that
about is going vegan
the right way
you know
and then
but then you just go on and you just
look and see what animals do to each
other how everybody is predator or prey
you know you got a bunch of [ __ ] out
there with flat [ __ ] teeth
like
people
and they have no claws they just have
hooves they give them horns
all right they get [ __ ] horns
like that guy in the upper deck
used to sell those big stupid plastic
horns when i was a kid and you go to a
football game and there'd just be some
guy
the upper deck you know where are all
those things they're all in the [ __ ]
ocean
um
so
yeah you got all these flat teeth things
that maybe they get horns or maybe they
can hop or run fast
or whatever and they just their job is
to just [ __ ]
and make more of them
so these these
murderers have something to eat
you know and i have to say the most
humane animal out there
is the big cats
all right
the big cats
because they just go right for your
throat
they [ __ ] choke you out and it's over
and if you listen to any of these ufc
fighters if they have the option of
getting knocked out or choked out they
all pick getting choked out
you know i guess if you're getting eaten
afterwards you don't give a [ __ ] if
you're knocked out but like they just
[ __ ] kill you and then they eat you
unlike [ __ ]
uh one of those goddamn giant [ __ ]
komodo dragons
or bears
or at least an alligator will [ __ ]
drown even that thing will start to eat
you alive it doesn't give a [ __ ] right
so
anyway so i i always wrestle with this
stuff but we really see like you know i
watched a guy over the last year this is
some big time white people [ __ ] right i
watched a [ __ ] guy become friends
with a octopus in an ocean
and i'm never eating octopus again
i'm never eating a [ __ ] octopus again
all right that's it i can't do it
all right and then
um
even if i go to italy
and that's the greatest octopus i ever
had because i was in [ __ ] rome it was
unbelievable i'm never i'm never eating
octopus again
and then i watch this documentary this
guy
he nurses this this
he rehabs
this this lobster
and the thing's having a ball and then i
was thinking like we'll get another one
so it's not lonely and then i was like
well i don't know if they would then go
at it you'd have to see one of one of he
called his lobster leon
i didn't want leon to die or whatever
but um
i don't know
i can never you know and then
then you have a brisket though but it
tastes so [ __ ] good you know it's
like what do i do here
i think i'm gonna go like i've been
wanting to do this for a while i'm gonna
go like two out of three meals
vegetarian
and then like one dead chicken
right
chickens is another one man you watch
these documentaries the way they what
the [ __ ] they do at kentucky fried
chicken
snip their beaks off they you know
people like breast meat so they [ __ ]
got them all roided up you know looking
like they played for the oakland a's in
the late 80s right they can't even walk
because they're [ __ ] tipping over
i remember one time i watched that you
are what you eat and i got all freaked
out and i tried to go around los angeles
right where all the twinkle toes [ __ ]
yoga people healthy people are i was
trying to find a [ __ ] healthy chicken
a regular chicken a real free-range
chicken and i finally found one
and the guy goes that's a chicken i go
that's a chicken that's not a pigeon
that's not a cornish hand you couldn't
believe how [ __ ] small this thing was
so um
i don't know we're getting back to the
dictator thing so i would uh
yeah i would just make you know
i would have once a month
would be junk food day
all right and my whole
cabinet
would have all the [ __ ] junk food
under lock
like jfk right before he put the embargo
on cuba he ordered like 1500 [ __ ]
cuban cigars so they could sit there
smoking him by the pool
after somebody begs marilyn monroe right
and then meanwhile all of us are [ __ ]
you know
having to drive up to canada
here's my thing on canada i don't think
cuba respects canada
i don't think they give them the best
cubans
you know i i really believe that the
best cubans go to like england
and israel
okay they want somebody with skin in the
game canada is too [ __ ] nice so when
they have a batch that isn't that good
they go let's send it to canada they're
not going to complain
all right
but england and israel you got to think
well these people might bomb us
i swear to god every time i smoke a
cuban cigar that somebody got from
england and like first of all cuban
cigars in general
you know even if they are [ __ ] real
they don't smoke it's like trying to
[ __ ] you know
it's like a
chocolate malt or something
and you got a little stir straw from a
for a chick drink trying to like get
it's the most frustrating thing ever
um
anyway
so i would do that
and i'd have people you know i would i
would somehow if there's a way to do
this by the way
if there's a way to have
local farmers be able to feed can local
farmers
feed seven billion people probably not
well then i don't want to watch people
starve to death so
i'd have to figure out how many people
they could feed
and then i got to start making cuts like
a [ __ ] nfl coach
in the beginning of august
all right so we have junk food
junk food johnny day once a month so 12
months out of the year you just get and
that's like a holiday
right
it's a holiday i already have you you're
only working three day weeks
all right but you're [ __ ] you're
going hard for three days
all right you work a 12-hour day a
12-hour day
no a 13 a 13 and then a 14 on wednesday
and then you have a four day [ __ ]
weekend every [ __ ] weekend
with nothing but good food to eat except
for once a month
you get junk food you get to go down and
you get [ __ ] junk food
for that whole four day [ __ ] weekend
and whatever you want to have [ __ ]
pizza and all of that [ __ ]
am i really gonna make people only eat
pizza once a month i would get
overthrown all right pizza is there's a
few exempts
pizza being one of them pizza is the
food of the people i got to let i got to
work this [ __ ] out
all right
and then i decide how many people
regular farmers can grow organic food
for
and then the rest of them gotta go
all right
and uh you know there'll be certain
criterias
people that walk around with something
funny written on their t-shirt done
you're dead you're gone
you're out of here all right people that
dress like it's a different period than
it is you're gone
you know you're walking around dressed
like a blacksmith you know get the [ __ ]
out of here
all right
that's it we would send you for
re-education meaning we're killing you
um so whatever that's just the beginning
i'm just scratching the surface um
women who say my heart breaks for
you know
so they don't make the tragedy still not
about the tragedy it's about them and
their feelings they're gone
all right
that's it
um
i'm kind of running out of people here
that'll get me down
a couple hundred thousand right there
um
so
then everybody's gotta start [ __ ]
help cleaning up the ocean
all right
airplanes have to become electric
all right and then also they don't end
up in those graveyards you have to keep
upgrading them like they do with the
cars in cuba
same thing with like teslas and whatever
electric cars that new [ __ ] ford
lightning
all of that [ __ ]
you just keep fixing them like they do
on gas monkey garage rather than
throwing them out or having them all
pile up and recycling actually works
right and people are nice to people i'm
trying to create a utopia um
and then that's it and i'd get rid of
the uh the last thing i would do is a
dictator i get i get rid of the um
the uh what do they call it the luxury
tax in baseball
that's it and when the yankees win the
world series you're not allowed to say
and all is right in baseball
okay
because that's [ __ ] stupid all is not
right in baseball they want why isn't
all is right when when [ __ ] the cubs
win it
all is right in baseball because now the
cubs fans finally get to know what it
feels no no
that's like the yankees winning a world
series and saying and all is right in
baseball is like watching some fatty eat
his fifth [ __ ] hamburger in a row and
being like and all is right
that [ __ ] chuck e cheese or whatever
all right so anyway
oh i would also yeah i'd uh
yeah and overthrow the [ __ ] banks and
the [ __ ] oil companies we would just
go in like michael corleone
or was it corleone i don't know and they
would just all get whacked like [ __ ]
mo green
that's
it that's it
okay at the end of the day they're only
bankers
okay so all i need to do is just get
their security team on my side
by promising them pizza organic food
and the fact that all is not going to be
right if the yankees win it the yankees
win congratulations but all is not right
okay and then the lakers actually have
to draft a championship team
the colts can't whine anymore this is
going to be you know i'm a dictator it's
going to be tipped towards boston sports
here okay i'm sorry it just it is what
it is
um
all right so here's so everybody i want
you guys to tell me what you do as a
dictator all right dictator rule for
fatties hey billy pinknips uh here oh
here's a rule i would implement
implement if i were a dictator all
airline ticket prices are calculated by
weight the heavier you are the more you
pay well i'll tell you airlines would
love that
because uh that does take up more jet
fuel uh when you buy your ticket online
you enter your weight
you get your ticket based oh my god can
you imagine all these people [ __ ]
crying
you know and then they realize there's
no place to cry anymore because there's
a dictatorship
and the dictator controls the internet
um you get your ticket based on the
weight you entered then the day you
travel
when you check in you have to weigh
yourself on the luggage scale
if you're you're heavier than the weight
you entered you'd pay the difference
well what if you're significantly
heavier and you know that the person
lied
do they get offed right there
it's my question anyway if you're
lighter you get a discount bags have to
weigh a certain amount because of fuel
cost why not people i have several more
dictator ideas but i'm putting them in a
new novel so i can't send them to you
love the redrock show you crush come to
utah please all right
i like that
we can't just go after the fatties what
about sociopaths
and uh
you know pedophiles
uh dictator uh dear billy red rocks i am
writing in to present my campaign for my
dictatorship i was actually debating
calling the uh special that billy red
rocks dean delray told me that call it
billy red rocks
and i was like should i do that my wife
go don't do that don't do that i go it's
kind of funny
but then how funny is it if even the
listeners guessed that joke i gotta do
better
uh am i i am right so now i'm just gonna
be live at red rocks clever um i'm
writing in to present my campaign for my
dictatorship which consists of two
points
i would immediately eradicate the robo
calls you get for car insurance
or whatever or whatever mainly because
they annoy the hell out of me this would
be my scheme to get the public on my
side for what i implement next
in my policy i love that
see this is a smart dictator little
bread and circus
this is where you get the people that go
yeah
they get on your side
uh number two this is this is this is
where i think it's going to get a little
stricter i would make dueling legal
dueling legal across the board
that's [ __ ] hilarious
if you feel you've been wronged in any
way
you have the legal right to challenge
the other people to a duel and should
they accept you would be allowed to
decide how to duel
and then potentially kill each other
there must be at least one witness to
each party should neither combatant die
the duel is a draw and any further
action taken would be subject to local
laws dude this is the most entertaining
way to thin the population
they should be televised televised duels
and then there would be even more duels
because people do anything they get on
tv
i i might hey listen i gotta tip my
napoleon
bonaparte hat to you or whatever
i give you two [ __ ]
vladimir putins on that one thumbs up
or what do they do they clasp their hand
and they shake it to the side of their
ear
now you know bummed out i am that we're
gonna get in a [ __ ] battle with
russia again what are we doing
hey [ __ ] i i live russia vodka hockey
tough people i mean what's what the [ __ ]
is the problem
jesus [ __ ] christ
what are we mad at that they're doing
what the [ __ ] we're doing oh you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
you [ __ ] goddamn
what the oh i thought it went out i
didn't go out what happened i think my
headphones went up wait a second am i
still going
it looks like it's still going yeah it
is
it just crapped out and then all of a
sudden it came back
all right whatever anyway i don't
understand why we're upset at russia
it's like stop doing what we're doing
we do that all the time
all right we're gonna go in places where
we don't belong and take [ __ ] over and
kill people then why can't they
um
i'm sure it's a little more complex than
that anyway um
or better yet why can't both of us just
stay the [ __ ] home and leave other
people alone
all right
so anyway should
should a combatant be killed in the duel
the victor would be safe from any
further legal action taken from the
losing participants side i.e if you
legally shoot someone in self-defense
you can still be sued civilly
by the family
this would not be the case in my regime
oh okay
well if you shoot somebody in
self-defense why can you well i guess
you can still be sued because they're
gonna because there's less burden of
proof
that's so dumb
um
anyway but what i'm seeing
is you know they've never they've never
televised paintball
you know because i think at the end of
the day it's just not interesting enough
to watch people saying ow
ouchie ow or you cheated
you know but imagine if
this was like the x-game version of
paintball where people actually [ __ ]
died
you know
i don't know what you would call it
shooting each other i don't know
um
comedy bang bang um i would also allow
inmates in prison to request a trial by
combat where they or someone who
or someone who agrees to fight for them
would fight a state-sponsored opponent
should the person die
they die should the prisoner win
they are cleared of all charges all
right that gets a little [ __ ] crazy
for me
i was with you i was really with you
until that part
um
you're gonna let a child molester kill
somebody from the [ __ ] state and then
they get to go fred i don't i don't
think about that
but whatever there's a lot of [ __ ]
holes in my [ __ ] too all right carlin's
agenda
it [ __ ] went out again wait a minute
is this just the screen going out
it is the screen's going out oh my god
this thing is it's getting old
i got to get a new olympus ls100
um all right
uh carlin's agenda
dear billy for the ages i'm really tired
of watching people co-opt george
carlin's comedy for their own political
bias
oh dude you're preaching to the choir
i have people going do you know what
carlin would think about your [ __ ]
stance on mass
he'd be rolling over in his grave it's
just like well what do you what do you
think he'd be thinking about
what do you think he'd be thinking if
you were speaking for him
after he was dead
what other dead comics do you speak for
what are you [ __ ] whoopi goldberg and
ghost
you channeling these people anyway carla
went after things he thought were bogus
not things that didn't align with some
tribal [ __ ] he was attached to
all right somebody who understands
george carlin beautiful i see liberals
use his videos to promote this listen to
the establishment the government
is never wrong [ __ ]
um
all right i got to tell you that that
that whole sentence is [ __ ]
all right first of all uh conservative
people also use it
you know this person was trashing me
about not wearing saying to wear masks
and then also liberals do not think that
the government is never wrong
they think the government is wrong if
the person in government is wearing a
red tie the way conservatives think the
government is wrong if the person is
wearing a blue tie
you know
am i right
anyway there are hours of carlin
trashing fake liberals who talk like
they care about the world but don't he
went hard at the use of native americans
when it emerged as some righteous
alternative to indians yes something you
brought up recently on the podcast yes
he also went hard at the military
industrial complex something that is
supported by both sides that's also
right he went hard at racism he hated
modern liberals for all their censorship
throughout the 80s and religious
conservatives in the 90s which came from
reagan-arab politics yes in 20 years i
see someone saying bill burr hated blank
without going after both sides
which are really one and the same at
this point i'm going to slap them in the
face with the dead fish um
no that already happens to anybody who
even remotely posts a video is people
are already everybody is acting like
their own little news channel and they
are spinning [ __ ] and clipping stuff to
make it
part of their agenda the amount of times
people have taken one of my jokes and
said see what he's saying here and they
are 100 wrong and they're not even going
like politically
so
um
yes
people do that to carl and [ __ ] all the
[ __ ] time
they do that and they walk around with
uh
who's that cuban guy jay guevara they
had those t-shirts for a long time they
uh who else is another big one
um
nostradamus
people like to quote him a lot
you know to make themselves seem deeper
uh kurt vonnegut was big in the
alternative comedy scene
there was a while there for about 18
months to two years where it was big
for an alternative comic to tag a joke
with and so it goes and so it goes
you know
and i used to always think like you know
there's a difference between being kurt
vonnegut and quoting kurt vonnegut
so don't quote the guy and also say oh
my god did you read the book that
everybody else [ __ ] read um
accidentally insulted girlfriend's bald
brother-in-law
oh my god i love this already uh bill
thinks he's better than me burr
and i do
i'm better than all you [ __ ] um
that right there is when you know
somebody's sad
it's when they think they're better than
you because they need to do that
okay i'm speaking from experience it's
why i always talk down to you guys and i
will never stop
talking down to you um
despite
my uh academic record
i've been seeing this girlfriend for
about four months now
and she invited me to come to her family
christmas celebration
i already met her mom dad and sister but
i never met her sister's fiance
flash forward everything's going well
we had got done with dinner and we were
all sitting in the living room watching
a christmas special oh my god this is
perfect
when i sub when i said something i
probably shouldn't have
uh her sister's fiance is about 25 and
balding and when i say balding i mean
he's got it bad
nothing on top
but the sides are bushy
bright orange hair well that's not
balding that's bald
he wears a hat
all the time
but he took it off and got off the couch
before i could even think i said
lieutenant dan you ain't got no hair
everyone went quiet for a bit then like
the champ that she is
she started laughing and playing it off
like it was nothing
oh your girlfriend did
but afterward
she told me that he was very
self-conscious about being a 25 year old
bald ginger well who wouldn't be
what should i do to fix it should i
apologize or act like nothing happened
since you're a bald ginger [ __ ]
i figured you'd have some insight that's
[ __ ] dude that was the longest [ __ ]
way to insult me and that was great go
fornicate yourself i have to [ __ ]
look up that reference lieutenant dan
you ain't got no hair what is that from
dan
you ain't oh you ain't got no legs
oh that's from forrest gump
first of all
you're [ __ ] hilarious that's a great
[ __ ] reference
did you say it like lieutenant dan you
ain't got no hair
wow
okay i'm calling [ __ ]
on your whole before i knew what
happened
before i could even think i just said
that no you're a [ __ ] and you knew what
you were doing
all right
yeah you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay but still what you said was
hilarious and he should have laughed it
off
uh but you're not a total [ __ ] because
you actually feel bad but i don't if you
actually feel bad cause you hurt the
guy's feeling you know
there's the jews say you're a mensch
right
does the gentiles say you're a [ __ ]
good [ __ ]
uh but if you're just doing it because
your girlfriend hasn't been [ __ ] you
lately then you're a [ __ ] um
all right what should i do to fix it
should i apologize or act like nothing
happened
um
oh that's a tough one
it makes it tougher because he's a
redhead
why does he have it all bushy just shave
your [ __ ] head man people will think
you know some jiu jitsu
maybe he should do that man
look i don't know what i don't know how
you fix that i don't think you can fix
it
um
what are you gonna say
sorry i said ye got no hair like force
gump in front of everybody during the
holidays while watching a christmas
special i mean how the [ __ ]
because he knows everybody's laughing
about it afterward
um
only thing i give advice to is the bald
ginger [ __ ] maybe you [ __ ]
just play him this
play him this [ __ ] uh
you know playing this podcast
shave your head buddy get in [ __ ]
ridiculous shape
get shredded
and that's it and you know what you'll
grow into your bald head
it won't be as weird as in your 30s and
then you've already dealt with the worst
thing that can happen to a guy when he's
aging
other than [ __ ] getting a terminal
disease you've already [ __ ] dealt
with it when you shave your head
ladies find it confident
they find it as confident as opposed to
combing it over or [ __ ] you know
reappropriating [ __ ] from the back of
your head and then walking around with
that 90210 haircut for the rest of your
[ __ ] life
um
or you could go that route
you could go there you know what i got
one for you i this is how you fix it
[ __ ] i got the best one ever
i got the best one ever i swear to god
if this [ __ ] recorder crapped out on
me
no it's still going all right
i got it i have it all right
we'll start i will i will [ __ ] put
some money towards this and i will we'll
do a we'll do a a gofundme
that won't have his name
we'll all know what it is
it's the lieutenant dan gofundme
all right you find where the best hair
transplant people are out there and and
and collectively between my listeners
and me we'll get him a [ __ ] hair
transplant
how about that
does that work
let me know
that would be amazing if that became my
charity
you know some people saved the whales
and then i could be the spokesperson and
still be bald so i'd look selfless
selfless you know and i'd be like the
martyr and he never took the time to do
it for himself
all right airplane graveyard this is the
last thing here and i really hope my
[ __ ]
recorder has not [ __ ] crapped out
it hasn't and for some reason
oh i know it's it's going into
screensaver mode
god i am stupid
all right airplane jesus bill that was
even bad for me
all right if i can just save one bald
ginger all right airplane
airplane graveyard
hi bill
um listening to your podcast where you
talk about flying up to victorville and
seeing all those jumbo jets i fly drones
and actually flew up
at the airplane graveyard up in the
mojave desert and got some epic shots of
those planes
hey tell me where that is i want to fly
up there here's the link to my video on
my youtube channel share if you enjoy it
i absolutely will i'm gonna i'm gonna
send that link i'm gonna
i'm gonna send that link and i'm also
gonna send you guys the i'll post the um
the lobster thing
i'm also gonna um
post the [ __ ] uh
the flyover and then also i'm gonna help
out that guy if he wants to get a hair
transplant
all right me and my listeners will help
him out and he can do it totally
anonymously
totally [ __ ] anonymously which means
the [ __ ] that said dan uh lieutenant
daniel you ain't got no hair
um
which jesus christ is so [ __ ] funny
on its own forget about that you did it
at your girlfriend's family house
to what could be your future
brother-in-law
while watching a christmas special i
mean that's just [ __ ] aces but we're
gonna we're gonna wrung that right
um
that's it all right that's the podcast
happy new year to everybody i hope you
have a happy
great year
get out of your own goddamn way as dave
elich says um which by the way he has a
whole new added thing if you want to get
better at drums davey lich get out of
your own way
look up look that up he hasn't on his
website
sorry hiccup and burpin and everything
here
um
that's it that is a podcast go [ __ ]
yourselves and i'll check in on you on
thursday